well one of your first acting jobs was
actually a Super Bowl commercial so
that's elevated
um I was like that's that's incredible
it was really very exciting it's still
exciting today to to watch it because I
wish I wasn't in a Super Bowl commercial
today I mean they're huge yeah
I felt like I was filming a movie like
that's how exciting it was well because
it's like the first thing yeah were you
more excited about craft services like I
always feel like every time I talk to
people they're always like craft
Services was incredible I I brought one
of our kids here today and I think he
was most excited about was the food that
was going to be around yeah check out
the hallway there's a big hallway full
of stuff you won't want him to eat yeah
um all right um so you come from a huge
football family I actually did not know
this about you but one of your parents
owns the Steelers and one owns the
Giants yeah
I'm gonna let that sit for a minute yeah
because I was like wait what and then
what are football games like at your
house because they get intense at my
house yeah and no one owns anything you
know we feel like we do in spirit but
like yeah yeah literally y'all own them
so like what what kind of chaos ensues
it of football like it's pretty wild my
dad's side of my family who are the
giant side of the family there's 11 kids
so my dad is one of 11. wow um so that's
insane anyway yeah and then they're all
psycho giant fans yeah so you can
imagine how crazy it is yeah emotionally
but then I married someone who is a
psycho um English football fan so we've
got football on the brain at all times
she means soccer in that sense yeah well
yes but I can't call it that's all I
know it's called football there I just
mean but so that's a lot of sports going
on in this household it's a lot yeah
it's a lot
um you've sung the National Anthem um so
if I at an NFL game so here's the thing
though yours was pretty intense yours
was an emotional one because it was a
connection to your family right oh yeah
I think one of the last I don't know why
I ever sang the national anthem I was a
young I'm not a singer I I definitely
should you are no like a fun I'll sing
in the shower or sing Disney songs but
my grandpa when he was alive
um used to ask me to sing it and so I
thought well yeah I should do that if he
asked me but now I just can't even I
don't know how I ever got the guts to do
it because again I don't feel confident
doing that I know but don't you wish you
could carry that over into like
adulthood like how even in the voice
when I have like younger artists that
I'm working with they don't even know to
be jaded or scared or fearful they just
go for it I know which is such a way
that you should live your life anyway so
I love that I almost wish we could carry
that over I wish yeah I wish I was as
Brave now as I was then for sure yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going home